hi this is presh talwalkar
there's a math problem everyone is
talking about and i wanted to share my
perspective
what is the correct answer to six
squared
divided by two parentheses three plus
four
some people are saying you should focus
on the two parentheses three part
and evaluate two times three to get six
then evaluate six squared divided by six
which is six
and finally you need to add four to get
an answer of ten
other people are saying you should look
at the expression from left to right
you first take 6 squared divided by 2
6 squared is 36 divided by 2 is 18
then multiply that by 3
to get 54
and finally you should add four to get
58.
so what's the correct answer is it 10 or
58
to settle the debate let's look to the
internet and see what we get when we
search for this question
wolfram alpha is a great website to
evaluate mathematical expressions
if we type in our question
we get the result
of 58.
we can also try searching for the
expression in google and when we do that
google calculator also says the answer
is 58.
all right that should settle the debate
between these two interpretations of the
problem
the answer of 58 is more consistent with
the common customs of mathematical
expressions
just because the two
and the three have a parenthesis next to
each other doesn't mean
we necessarily evaluate it first
that parentheses around the three
is interpreted as a multiplication sign
and by the order of operations it makes
more sense to evaluate this from left to
right
but if there's any debate it's because
the expression is written with an
ambiguous meaning
let me ask you a question what's the
correct meaning to the following
sentence
i saw the man with binoculars
one person could look at the sentence
and say oh this sentence means i saw the
man
with binoculars that is i was using
binoculars to see the man
another person could say no no the
sentence means i saw the man with
binoculars you were actually looking at
someone who had binoculars
so just as there are english expressions
that can be interpreted in different
ways if you have parentheses
there are also mathematical expressions
that can be ambiguous if you don't write
them in a way that the reader can
interpret them correctly
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions
which you can follow on facebook google
plus and patreon
you can also catch me at preshtalwalkar
on twitter instagram tumblr and
pinterest
and you can also check out my books on
math and game theory
there's a link in the video description
thanks for watching